we've lost
40 percent of our business
what began as a health crisis has become
an economic catastrophe
there's only so much we can do and until
people fly more
we're a little bit stuck coronavirus has
grounded entire industries
leaving world leading manufacturers
counting the cost
and cutting jobs i feel like maybe even
alongside 50 i'm on the scrap beat now
there's 800 applicants for one job
heaven knows when he could find a job
but what has been the impact beyond the
boardroom and the factory floor
i tend now not to look any further than
about a week ahead
to investigate the real cost of kovic 19
we've spoken to bosses suppliers and
small businesses
workers families and communities on the
brink
this is the story of the economic virus
it's extremely hard to make ends meet
but if you don't come out you don't get
anything
[Music]
coronavirus has scorched economic
certainties
it's penetrated every corner of working
life exposing
structural weaknesses and the
vulnerability of jobs dependent
on an interconnected world
skilled experienced and committed david
spent nine years working for a
contractor on the airbus production line
in broughton north wales
but when planes were grounded he was
among more than 400 people
made redundant it's quite frustrating
you know you spend your time
writing to companies sending your cvs
and stuff and
you get no response back uh none at all
not
sure i feel like i don't know maybe
maybe even the wrong side of 50 i'm on
the scrappy now you know
absolutely anything absolutely
obviously i need ideal would be
something on a comparable salary but
at the moment that's just not around
can't be a postman i can put an aircraft
together yeah
yeah it's a bit of a kick in the teeth
[Music]
really
the family now rely on wife louise's
part-time job
and eking out david's redundancy payment
while he looks for work
their priority to keep funding daughter
emily's passion for dance
a talent that has seen her represent
wales at a world cup
i'm trying to take the pressure off the
bills
i will really want her to carry on
dancing and i don't want that to be
impacted
but then you have to look at the cost so
is there classes that she can cut
to save on that so it's just it's a
horrible horrible
situation to be in it's you know it's
it's worrying about
how long is it going to take him to find
a job there's 800 applicants for one job
how how do you compete with that
on that basis heaven knows when he could
find a job
this is where david worked wellington
bombers for the war effort were once
built on this site
now a new enemy threatens production of
wings for airbus's commercial fleet
[Music]
this is a major part of a global
business worth 65 billion pounds last
year
but the outbreak has devastated aviation
and around 1400 people
25 of the workforce here could lose
their jobs
the boss told me why we've lost
since the crisis probably 40 percent of
our business
which shows shows the scale of the
impact we don't see
even flights returning to the
pre-covered levels before
2023 at the earliest maybe even as far
out as 2025.
any person who has to leave a job it's
difficult
but if it just shows the reality of the
situation facing us
in contrast to france and germany the
british aviation industry has had no
direct government aid airbus says
subsidizing shorter working hours
could reduce redundancies in in our
industry
it's no good extending a furlough for
three months because our
our ultimate situation won't have
changed in three months
rather than making some of the employees
redundant we could reduce the working
week for a bigger number of employees
when wings are completed they're flown
for final assembly and toulouse in vast
cargo planes that dock
in this purpose-built hangar one piece
in an
international jigsaw airbus is
an industrial giant supporting more than
a hundred thousand direct employees
in the uk and around the world and many
more
at its thousands of suppliers but the
strength
of that interconnectedness is a weakness
when it comes to coronavirus
the collapse in air travel has caused an
economic contagion
that threatens jobs and livelihoods at
every link
in the chain
broughton is a small town now buffeted
by global headwinds
but this corner of the country is no
stranger to industrial pain
paul davies can remember when six and a
half thousand steel workers lost their
jobs here in the 1980s
power steel and paper are still all
produced by the river d as well as
planes
but they've all had to change to survive
it's one of the biggest employers now in
the
in the area i've certainly got relatives
including a son and a grandson who's
just had an apprenticeship there
i don't think anybody in the area
doesn't know somebody who works out or
doesn't have a relative who works there
so it's going to affect everybody
80 miles west derby is also counting the
cost of coving
this is a city steeped in manufacturing
planes
trains and automobiles the biggest of
all
is a british household name
rolls royce engines hang beneath airbus
wings and they're tested
in this vast facility but nothing
could prepare the company for the
collapse of air travel and with it
it's business model
rolls royce like other engine companies
is paid per flying hour
by airlines to look after the engines
and service them
because that money dries up you have to
sort of adjust everything
there's only so much we can do until
people fly more
we're a little bit stuck with air travel
unlikely to recover to pre-pandemic
levels for four years
rolls-royce has already made 2 900
redundancies in the uk
around half of them here we've been
losing a lot of
our colleagues over the last few months
you know redundancy is really painful
it's the last thing you do in business
it takes years to build up skills and
you know
people are colleagues they're also our
friends
there are 38 000 parts in one of these
engines 30
of them made by rolls royce the rest by
companies
across the uk and around the world
[Music]
this is one of those parts it's made by
naismith
a precision engineer 20 miles away near
mansfield
that's felt the human cost of covid
directly
unfortunately one of our employees died
of kevin 19 in one of our other
businesses
and we had a guy for this business that
was on a ventilator for about
four or five weeks 200 out of 800 staff
have been made redundant
their priority now is to be ready when
demand returns
we're trying to preserve that the skill
level
so sadly maybe people that aren't as
skilled as others
the ones we had to make redundant so
it's it's quite heartbreaking at times
to
um to see that and the human cost is
associated with it
[Applause]
the collapse of a global industry has
local consequences
in derby rolls-royce staff are the
engine of the economy
the customers of businesses like
allison's sandwich shop
starved of trade by the move to working
from home
it was devastating really i mean i'm
still open i'm still here
but people are losing the jobs
rolls royce always has a knock-on effect
to other businesses and people
that supply them and service them people
like ourselves
right down to you know our little shop
here
there's a huge chain with all of this we
drawing locked down
our bakery went into administration
they've not reopened again since
so we had to find another bakery
business visitors to the city have dried
up too with disastrous consequences for
the cab drivers
who usually keep derby moving royals
royce is a
massive issue 80 hour jobs in the
morning were all rolls-royce
which are no longer here so it's
obviously affecting not just the taxi
trade but also the hotels and
small shops and the rest i don't think
it's going to improve
much at all because uh most people will
carry on
working from home it's very difficult
you don't believe it you know
you have to wait here sometime even up
to three hours for to get a job i mean
this morning i was here before nine and
up till now
doing only two jobs and there's been
good few months
hardly even took anybody through the
ruiz in the morning it used to be like
even eighty percent to traders to rose
ruiz at the minute
is a full shift if you do it max to 12
hour shift
and that is a tyrant is maybe 30 40 quid
when times get hard this is one of the
places people turn
doorways derby is a food bank that's one
of the few businesses expecting to get
busier this winter
people that used to donate to doorways
sort of last year the year before
their position is they're coming up and
using our products table and perhaps
having food parcels delivered to
themselves as well
because of the furlough lack of money um
and just trying to keep the head above
water really
with unemployment rising earnings
squeezed and restrictions on work and
socializing extended even being in work
like waitress natasha may not be enough
with like the kobit 19 and everything
everybody's been put on short hours
with having shorter hours you never know
how much you're going to come
out with and sometimes the money doesn't
stretch
far enough week before i get paid
is the most difficult weeks you've got
to wait until
payday next week and it's just
hard to stretch it all out
what's happening to people and
businesses in broad and derby is being
replicated in other industries and other
towns and cities
across the country leaving companies
fighting for survival i tend now
not to look any further than about a
week ahead
really yeah because i just don't know
what's around the corner anymore
and workers who lose their jobs paying
the greatest price
of an economy shaped by the virus
it feels like the whole economy has been
destroyed
there's nothing there for anybody
especially people who've been doing jobs
like i've been doing
there's no industry there's no no
manufacturer
so what we meant to do
you